H
NORWAY.
NEIL?
>> Neil: THANKS, TREY.
BE SAFE.
I WANT TO GO TO LEON PANETTA,
THE FORMER CIA DIRECTOR WHO TOLD
SKY NEWS NOT LONG AGO -- I WAS
INTRIGUED BY THIS COMMENTS ABOUT
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
WHEN VLADIMIR PUTIN IS CORNERED,
HE'S DANGEROUS.
WHEN YOU CORNER A BULLY, A BULLY
CAN BE VERY DANGEROUS.
HE'S AT THAT STAGE RIGHT NOW.
>> THERE'S NO QUESTION, NEIL.
AT THIS POINT PUTIN IS FLIGHTING
A TWO-FRONT WAR.
ONE IN UKRAINE AND ONE IN
MOSCOW.
HE'S GOT HARDLINERS THAT ARE
CRITICIZING HIM FOR THE WAY THIS
WAR IS GOING.
AND IT'S PRETTY CLEAR THAT THE
TIDE OF WAR HAS REALLY CHANGED
IN UKRAINE.
PUTIN IS LOSING.
SO AS A RESULT OF THAT, HE IS
FEELING CORNERED.
WHEN HE'S CORNERED, PUTIN WILL
STRIKEOUT AS BULLIES WILL WHEN
THEY'RE BASICALLY PREVENTED FROM
USING ANY OTHER OPTIONS.
HE'S IN A PLACE WHERE HE DOESN'T
HAVE A LOT OF PLACES TO GO.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES HIM VERY
DANGEROUS RIGHT NOW.
>> Neil: HE SEEMS HOT AND COLD,
LEON.
NOW THIS LATEST OVERTURE, HE
SAYS HE'S DONE WITH HIS MILITARY
CALL-UP.
AT THE TIME WE WERE ABOUT
220,000 RUSSIAN SOLDIERS.
WE'RE GETTING THIS FROM HIM.
I DON'T KNOW HOW ACCURATE IT IS.
IT'S CLOSE TO THE 300,000 HE
WANTED.
HE HAD A DEVIL OF TIME GETTING
RESERVISTS IN THE FIRST PLACE.
MOST WERE TRYING TO FLEE THE
COUNTRY.
WHAT IS THE REAL DEAL?
>> WELL, IT GOES BACK TO WHAT I
SAID.
HE'S CONFRONTING PROBLEMS BACK
IN MOSCOW.
HE'S HAD A HARD TIME MOBILIZING
THE FORCES THAT HE'S BEEN TRYING
TO PUT TOGETHER.
A LOT HAVE BEEN LEAVING.
THERE'S REALLY A LOT OF
CRITICISM ABOUT THE WAR GOING ON
IN MOSCOW.
ADD TO THAT, THE HARDLINERS THAT
ARE BEING VERY CRITICAL OF
WHAT'S GOING ON.
YOU PUT ALL OF THAT TOGETHER,
YOU KNOW, HE'S HAVING A HARD
TIME BEING ABLE TO PUT TOGETHER
THE KIND OF MILITARY CAPABILITY
THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO RESPOND IN
UKRAINE.
THE UKRAINIANS ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF IT.
THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO TAKE OVER
LITERALLY OVER 1,000 SQUARE
MILES BOTH IN THE EAST AND THE
SOUTH AND THEY WILL CONTINUE TO
DO THAT.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT THEY
SHOULD DO, VERY FRANKLY.
CONTINUE THEIR OFFENSIVE TO PUSH
PUTIN AND RUSSIA OUT OF UKRAINE.
THAT'S THE EFFORT THAT THEY
OUGHT TO BE PUSHING.
>> Neil: I CAN'T SEE AN END GAME
TO THIS.
IF HE CHOOSES TO, YOU KNOW,
LEAVE UKRAINE OR A WAY TO END
THIS WAR, HE'S GOT TO LEAVE WITH
SOMETHING.
HE HAS SAID THOSE ANNEXED
TERRITORIES ARE GIVEN.
THE UKRAINIANS, AS YOU INDICATE
IT'S NOT A GIN.
THEY'RE WINNING LANDS BACK.
SO WHAT IS IT?
HE'S LISTENING TO HARDLINERS
SAYING DOUBLE DOWN.
A GOOD MANY OF RUSSIANS SHOWING
FOR PROTESTS ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY AND THOSE THAT ARE
RELUCTANT TO BE CALLED UP FOR
THIS WAR, THAT'S NOT A GOOD WAR
TO THEM.
HE'S KIND OF STUCK.
>> THESE A GOOD WAY TO PUT IT.
HE IS STUCK.
INTELLIGENCE CONTINUES TO SAY
THAT PUTIN IS NOT AT A POINT
WHERE HE'S PREPARED TO NEGOTIATE
OR TRY TO FIND AN OFF RAMP HERE.
SO HE'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO
DOUBLE DOWN.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HE'S DOING
WITH THESE MISSILE BARRAGES.
ALTHOUGH I THINK AGAIN, THAT'S A
SIGN OF WEAKNESS.
IN THOSE MISSILE BARRAGES, HALF
ARE BEING TAKEN DOWN.
THEY ARE NOT BEING EFFECTIVE AT
TRYING TO PARALYZE UKRAINE IN
TERMS OF INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING RIGHT
NOW THAT THE UNITED STATES AND
THE ALLIES NEED TO DO IS TO
DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE AIR
DEFENSE SYSTEM FOR UKRAINE.
ISRAEL IS ABLE WHEN HAMAS SENDS
MISSILES OUT TO KNOCK DOWN OVER
90% OF THOSE MISSILES.
WE NEED TO SEE THE SAME KIND OF
CAPABILITY GIVEN TO THE
UKRAINIANS.
>> Neil: WHAT DO WE DO ABOUT THE
SAUDIS?
THEY LED THIS EFFORT ON THE PART
OF OPEC COUNTRIES TO CUT
PRODUCTION, TWO MILLION BARRELS
A DAY.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS PROMISED
TO RESPOND.
SOME SAY STOP SENDING THE SAUDIS
ARMS, PERIOD.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO?
>> LOOK, I'M A BELIEVER THAT THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING WE NEED TO
DO IN THE MIDDLE EAST IS TO
BUILD STRONG ALLIANCES WITH OUR
MODERATE ARAB FRIENDS IN THE
MIDDLE EAST ALONG WITH ISRAEL.
THAT'S THE BEST WAY TO DEAL WITH
TERRORISM AND IT'S THE BEST WAY
TO DEAL WITH IRAN.
WE HAD THAT KIND OF RELATIONSHIP
WITH SAUDI ARABIA IN THE PAST.
I HOPE WE CAN GET BACK TO THAT
KIND OF RELATIONSHIP.
BUT I THINK IT'S TOO
IMPORTANT --
>> Neil: MODERATE FRIENDS DON'T
CUT PRODUCTION AND RAISE COSTS
ON YOU.
WHATEVER THEIR BEEF WITH IS THIS
PRESIDENT.
I CERTAINLY GET THAT.
I'M WONDERING, ARE THEY REALLY
OUR FRIENDS WHEN THEY DO
SOMETHING LIKE THAT?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I THINK THE
WAY TO APPROACH THIS IS TO --
THROUGH DIPLOMACY.
SENDING PEOPLE DIRECTLY TO SAUDI
ARABIA TO TALK THESE ISSUES
THROUGH.
I THINK THEY WILL LISTEN.
WE HAVE A LOT OF LEVERAGE ON
SAUDI ARABIA WITH REGARD TO
WEAPONS.
I WOULD HATE TO SEE THAT
RELATIONSHIP GO SOUR RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE FRANKLY, THE MIDDLE EAST
IS ANOTHER AREA THAT WE NEED TO
PAY ATTENTION TO.
WE HAVE FAILED STATES.
WE HAVE PROBLEMS WITH TERRORISM.
WE HAVE PROBLEMS WITH IRAN.
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE TRY TO PUT TOGETHER A STR